left-hander you say kikuchi is on the
mound for the seattle mariners this
season he has a 0-0 record two games
he's started he's got two quality starts
under his belt so he adds up to 12
innings last time out he was against
minnesota in minnesota where he went six
strong gave up two earned runs gave up a
home run and threw 94 pitches he's
pitched in five games against the astros
and has a career 6.46 era against the
astros right away two down and that'll
bring up left fielder michael brantley
nice first inning for kikuchi you gotta
like that a one two three first nine
pitches jose or keady on the mound for
the astros today and erkidi got the
losses last time out saturday against
oakland but went six innings which is
huge right now for the astros rotation
sega great road trip eight for 23 two
homers seven runs batted in swing and a
miss a breaking ball in the dirt picked
out of the dirt by castro he'll throw to
first to get the out and it's an
efficient one two three inning for jose
or keaney so the astros have their first
base runner and that'll bring up the
shortstop carlos correa swinging a
ground ball two hopper is short jp's got
it over to france for one relitter first
and it's in time for the double play
what a quick release by j.p crawford
over to france
in the middle of the pivot so two outs
for the astros here in the top half of
the second those are some kind of gold
glove hands of jp crawford the mariners
start to make some noise here in the
second inning here's center fielder
taylor trammell and tramell hits it in
the air
right field shallow this is actually on
the first space side guriel in the foul
territory makes the catch over by the
coaches box
and that's a big first out
one out and the banner will be right
fielder dylan moore dylan off to a slow
start this year strike three call on the
outside corner froze moore with a
fastball and that is the second
strikeout for katy two out so still two
on but now two out for tom murphy the
catcher batting 182 in seven games four
for 22. and that's hit in the air to
center right at straw back pedals a
couple of steps waiting for it makes the
catch and the inning is over sir katie
gets out of a first and second no out
jam
coochie
is allowed one base runner was taken out
and wiped out in a double place not
giving up a run or a hit two outs here
in the top of the fourth swung on line
drive on a hop to the shortstop crawford
on the other side of the bag with a
shift on he picks it totally smokes what
a start for you say kikuchi right now
he's locked into a scoreless game with
you say kikuchi that ball's popped high
in the air keaney says who wants it
nobody sees it and finally making the
catches of led miss diaz he had no idea
where that ball was and her kitty is
happy because finally olympus found that
it could have been a little pop-up
infield hit
it was up in the sky it's tough to see
right now
and just found it at the last second and
dove
just before that ball caught the grass
what a play by diaz
gucci no runs no hits face the minimum
through four thanks to a double play
after a walk in the second inning correa
first pitch swinging finds some open
space in left center field there is the
astros first hit of the night
with one out in the fifth inning correa
single in the left center
for the first time tonight the astros
have multiple base runners so here's
alex degoti struck out in his first big
league played appearance first big
league game tonight on the ground right
side that's a base hit alex degote a
single to right field coming in to score
correa the throw wide at third here
comes taylor jones he'll score astros
lead two nothing on the first major
league hit by alex degoti
congratulations alex
again another moment that a young astro
will never forget getting that first big
league hit here in seattle to put the
astros on the board how about that get
it out of the way early
first big league hit first big league
rbi and then it turned into a complete
yard sale
as a throw from dylan moore gets past
kyle seeger over there at third base so
the astros able to strike first still
only one out to go to its second base
for chas mccormick who flied out his
first time mccormick rips one to left
center field that ball is down and all
the way to the wall degote sprinting
home but he can walk home and chas
mccormick into second base with an rbi
double
three-nothing astros
easy read for alex
also for omar lopez easy to wheel him
around and score that run the astros
going out there and barreling up kikuchi
in this inning so second and third
nobody out in arcadi facing kyle seeger
seeger with runners in scoring position
this year hitting a smooth 500. swinging
its line into right field fair ball base
head rolling into the corner hanniger is
in to score ty france comes rumbling
around seeger a spikes first slide into
second base and kyle singer just
continues to drive in runs for the
mariners it's a one-run game career
extra base hit number 506 and counting
for kyle seeger
driving it down that right field line to
drive in a couple mr double
kyle seeger and the mariners are right
back in this ball game what a start to
the year for kyle seeger now hitting it
300 on the year with two home runs
and now with 12 runs batted in man he's
been suffering the astros have them all
around and here's the lebanese diaz a
little hesitation and a base hit for
olympus diaz in the left field one run
scores here comes degote he's going to
score two rbi single and the astros
regain their three run lead it is five
to two
what a big two-out hit for the astros
and it's five to two now
boy did they need that
we talked earlier about their hitting
woes with runners in scoring position
over their five-game losing streak and
that time i believe that was a change-up
from cacucci already a multi-hit night
for mitch haniger a couple of singles he
is the tying run at the plate there you
go
down the right field line murphy scores
jp to third
[ __ ] hannigan checking in again 5-3
ball game a three-hit night for mitch
haniger oh it's a great piece of hitting
right here it's a slider right on the
outside corner and and mitch hadiger
just gets down low and man still is able
to have a nice level swing as he as his
body goes after that pitch and drives it
the other way into right field his third
hit tonight one out runners on the
corners go ahead run at the plate ty
france he swings lashes this high and
deep out to right center field back out
of the warning track two-hand catch
mccormick by the bill of his cap
crawford tags strolls home
steps on the plate
it is now a one-run game type france sac
fly right field
5-4 houston one out for the mariners
here in the bottom of the eighth inning
breaking ball hammered left
[Applause]
line drive into the houston pin straight
away left field
for the mariners their
eighth consecutive game with a home run
number one for evan white it's now the
mariners five and the astros five taylor
trammell will stand in that's a ground
ball softly hit right side taylor off
the mound trying to glove flip it the
first can't do it and now taylor is
shaken up as he's hopping around on his
left foot and he is in some pain
tried to make a great play on that ball
nubbed off the end of the bat of tramell
oh man that ankle
rolled that ankle up on the right side
now they're trying to figure out a way
to get taylor off the field back inside
the clubhouse they're bringing a card
out for him yeah
now the pitch
and that's a ground ball left side deep
in the hole backhanded by correa long
throw to first on a hop and it's in time
to retire more
fantastic play by carlos correa
showing off that strong arm in the hole
momentum
carrying him away from first base
intentionally bounced that throw just
trying to get into the direction of
first
game-winning run second base j.p
crawford plus speed
here's the stretch by pressly swinging a
fly ball deep into the gap in right
center field here comes crawford ronnie
third down the stretch he comes he will
score
ty france with a walk walk-off rbi
single here in the bottom of the ninth
inning and the mariners come from behind
defeat the astros here at t-mobile park